welcome back to safety blitz he's rodney
harris jack collinsworth rod it is turn
the page tuesday so those who need to
look beyond what we saw from sunday or
monday we'll start with the new england
patriots everybody's so high on mack
jones josh mcdaniels this new
combination what do they need to turn
the page on right there in new england
well josh has to come up with a better
game plan unfortunately because
it just seems like everything is
stagnant everything's quick everything's
kind of predictable
and i i want to see him open up this
offense give this kid the ball let him
let him throw the ball down the field
they spend so much money on all these
weapons and john smith hunter henry
these guys have to start making plays
coach belichick guaranteed these guys a
lot of money and paid johnny smith
50 million dollars 50 million dollars he
has to get his confidence back and he
has to be able to
hold on to the ball
it's kind of a weird situation when you
when you look at their rasha right now
and like who who's the receiver who's
the who's the great wide receiver on
that roster i mean they put a bunch of
resources into nikhil harry to be that
guy they took him at the end of the
first round and everybody was scratching
their head going a little bit nikhil
harry there you had dk metcalf who was
still sitting on the board why going to
kill harry it didn't make sense at the
time and now he's really become a bust
and it makes even less sense now so then
you go pay a bunch of money into two
tight ends which is something they've
had in the past in new england two great
tight ends on the field at the same time
trying to recreate that you would think
but can mak jones be successful without
a great wide receiver on the outside do
they need to get him more help at the
receiver position or can you do it with
just two great tight ends
no i mean they have they have kendrick
bourne who's a very solid player they
have nelson aguilar jacoby myers they
got guys that can make plays the bottom
line is it starts up front they have to
get tougher at the point of attack on
the offensive line and when you can run
the ball and that's a staple with the
patriots i know everybody thought that
the patriots are a passing team but at
the end of the day this is a team that
establishes the run and does everything
off the play-action pass and all those
different things that you see so they
have to re-establish the offensive line
and get tougher and start running the
ball and what happened to
randray stevenson he was a man that you
couldn't stop in the preseason all of a
sudden he doesn't have clothes on i
don't understand that with coach
belichick there's a lot of things that i
agree with coach belichick and i'm not
there practicing every single day but if
i had that kid randre stevenson as big
and as fast as he is as fresh as he is
there's no way he'd be sitting on the
sideline in street clothes
let's get to a team who has history with
the new england patriots the seattle
seahawks you said their defense needs to
turn that page where specifically
it just seems like they're so really
really talking about predictability
they're very predictable and this
defense is based on jamal adams you know
pressure jamal adams jamal adams
sometimes you can't always blitz your
strong safety you know what i mean
sometimes you got to keep two safeties
back and to me i look at that front four
and i just don't see the constant
consistent pressure that they need they
need to be able to create turnovers they
need better pass rush they need to be
able to tackle an open field and this
this team won't go very far in the
playoffs always blitzing jamal adams
because now all of a sudden you leave
your corners on an island i think your
corners are solid they're not great and
if you're not getting there with the
pass rush then he has to be the guy
always trying to create pressure and
that just opens up so many holes and
gaps in your defense so until their
defense comes around and start being
able to get
pressure with the front four
i think it's going to be an up and down
season for them
and i don't know who that pressure is
going to come from carlos dunlap leads
the team in creating pressure like
you're talking about dunlap long career
in cincinnati great years here in
cincinnati was kind of on the tail end
of all of that and gets picked up over
there with seattle alton robinson who
was a fifth round pick out of syracuse
back in 2020 another player that's
played well on that defensive front
given you know what it's been for that
defensive front but those are sort of
the names that you're looking at to
create those kind of pressures and none
of them are sort of top tier pass
rushers if you will your third turned
the page for this tuesday frank reich
and the colts you've been critical of
them all along 0-3 now
what about the latest loss
you have carson wentz as your
quarterback
so what am i going to do drop back and
throw the ball 30 40 times no i got
jonathan taylor i got a huge offensive
line one of the top five offensive lines
in all of football and he's what he was
probably in the top three last year in
terms of total yards as a running back
he was like third he was third i guess
overall in terms of um yards run him
turn around and give him the ball 20 to
25 times what about nahim hines he was a
dual threat he could run the ball he can
come out the backfield like frank wright
has totally it seems like he's totally
changed his offense to fit around carson
wentz and carson wentz is terrible right
now he's just not very good he's not
playing with a lot of confidence he's
not stepping into his throws and this is
the thing that we talked about jack like
okay
this is perfect for carson wentz he's
familiar with the coach he's familiar
he's got players and playmakers around
him how can you mess this up how can you
mess this up and you got jonathan taylor
you got all these other weapons and you
got good tight ends
well they're messing it up so far
because they're playing teams that are
better than them i i was going back and
watching some of their games so they
lost to seattle i lost the seahawks the
seahawks are just better than them i
mean you know russell wilson's better
their defense is better andy's this new
group trying to figure it out on the fly
and carson wentz is hurt he's got two
sprained ankles which i think has been
tough on him because if he does have any
elements of his game that will survive
as a starter in this league he has to be
able to incorporate athleticism and when
he's got two sprained ankles that's been
tough on him trying to create some of
that athleticism the rams and the titans
are their two other losses i mean i
on paper i mean just when you look at
the other teams that they're playing i
mean i really think that they've lost to
three better teams would you agree with
that are all three of those teams better
no than india in your eyes
really no why not i wouldn't agree with
that i don't think that i wouldn't think
the titans like the titans are on that
level with the coach but i'm i've been
saying this
he's just not very good like when you
talk about a quarterback and the impact
that a quarterback has on a team he's
had a negative impact on the team he's
had a negative impact on the team you
mean to tell me that the coats are that
much worse as a team
they're that much worse than what they
were last year it's because of the
quarterback i'm i'm telling you it's
just because the quarterback i'm not
going to sugarcoat it carson wentz isn't
very good and once the coach started
playing better then you're going to sit
back and say wow the coats are really
playing well because carson wentz
playing well if if he doesn't play well
the team's not going to play well
i want to wait till he gets a little bit
healthier i know he's going out there
he's trying to tough it out it's hard
when you're in a new city too but unless
an injuries have been a big part of his
career i mean if you look back at his
first four or five years in the nfl he's
missed a lot of time because of injuries
now he's got those two spring ankles and
he's trying to play with them and play
through them and it's not exactly
working out so flip it to the other side
of the ball with indy then for me rod
if you're not a believer in wince and
what he's doing with this offense and
what he's doing with frank reich
what about on the defensive side what
does this indianapolis defense look like
to you
man they got some players they got
players they got deforest buckner and um
leonard i mean they got some they got
some good you know good guys back there
in the secondary they got some players
but sometimes if you're if your offense
is struggling then all of a sudden
defensively you're trying to do too much
you're trying to create negative plays
you're trying to get interceptions
turnovers now you run out of your
responsibility and you get exposed and
that's exactly what's happening they're
frustrating indie because you look
around and you see the talent that they
have all the guys that they have
um jonathan taylor you're looking like
we're not running a ball why are we
dropping back passing the ball we have
to do he's 2 30 he runs a 4-3 and you're
not giving him the ball and he was third
in the nfl that's i blame that on the
head coach because what he's trying to
do he's trying to make um carson wentz
that guy as a poet
he's just not very good at this point in
time and it's your job as a head coach
to understand that and do something a
little different
well he's gonna this whole this whole nd
regime is gonna come down to those two i
mean it's either gonna be they're gonna
make it work with carson wentz or frank
reich's probably gonna leave the
building and carson wentz very well may
leave the entire nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports